Look Who's Back how you doing now you're
almost unrecognizable I know man it's uh
compared to who you were uh what was it
seven months ago seven months ago July
yeah
it's hard to believe it is man yeah it's
it's uh
I still
um show people that video and they I'll
be I'll have it like playing in the
house where I'm staying and stuff like
that and people look and be like who's
that guy I'm sitting right there I'm
like that's me dude they'll be like do a
double take I didn't recognize you when
you walked in it was your eyes that
really kind of like oh I know this
person yeah man it's uh I got eyebrows
and hair now a couple more tattoos and a
couple pounds yeah I do no I was I was I
think I clocked in it like
because I went to the hospital like a
week after that interview
I think I clocked in at like 120 pounds
120 pounds yeah I've been hitting the
gym my mind at a buck 90 now
how tall are you six foot even six foot
120 pounds yeah bad bad all that what
were we using uh meth and Fentanyl
um
yeah man it was uh it's really bad I
think uh
last year
um I overdosed 13 times 20 22. really
yeah being out here it's uh
sound for me man
but what what got you to turn the corner
um I think I attribute a lot of it to
Max
um max got fed up with my [__]
um which understandably so I'm a scumbag
when I'm using
um we had moved back to Milwaukee where
Max is from had an excellent opportunity
handed to me
um I'd almost lost my leg like a week
after he interviewed me to group a strep
I was laid out on the bus stop on um
she said uh seventh big and uh could not
get up
I mean like my leg was swollen insanely
large from a an abscess an abscess yeah
it was just I'd popped a popped a black
head on my knee
it's crazy
and um
it was something that uh I thought would
have been an eye-opening experience for
me and my mother thought it was going to
be too she uh flew all the way out from
Georgia to come stay with me in the
hospital and convinced me to come back
home to Georgia for a week or so your
family is solid right oh absolutely
[__] lutely my parents are
the best my my friends at home my sister
I mean like I I'm I'm a prime example of
someone who has a decent background
who still
you know addiction doesn't discriminate
has no doesn't give a [__] who you are
doesn't care where you come from you can
be from
uh I think I can't remember what song it
was you can be from Park Avenue or from
apartment you know it doesn't give [__]
you know you're gonna be
you're you're if you have that
personality trait if you have that
Obsession of the mind and that allergy
of the body you are going to
you're gonna
get hooked you know anything I do are
there other people in your family that
uh
um a similar problem uh my granddad he
was um
he had a prescription pill addiction he
was in a really bad alcoholic
on my dad's side and then
um my dad smokes weed he drinks beer you
know other than that you know my dad's a
solid stand-up functioning you know guy
my ma she uh has wine with dinner you
know classic Suburban white mother but
not out of control like you were no
never that no my parents are um my
mother's first husband was a heroin
addict and uh he actually died
when I was really young of um
complications with hep C cirrhosis I
think is what it was just left untreated
but you're you're biological my
biological father is still around he's
he's truly like like I said in the
interview last time he's still
he was my best friend when I was a kid
and these days I'm grateful to have
restored that relationship your family's
got to be really happy they are they're
extremely proud of me
they're really proud of me like I've got
30 days today like that's
something that I've had recovery in
clean time before
but last time you interviewed me I would
have never thought you know I was
pretty much convinced that I was gonna
die out on the streets if people were
going to take bets on whether you're
going to recover or die oh they're
they're monetary bets out there are I
think the vet was that you were gonna
I've had clean time based on a
resentment before just out of spite
despite sobriety
whatever what do you think LED you down
that path I mean it's more than just
it's more yeah it was genetics yeah well
I mean it was it was definitely uh just
what I thought was cool growing up you
know I looked up to all the wrong people
I thought that you know
whether it was
you know being just the gnarliest
craziest punk rocker you could be or
being the uh
being the bad guy I always thought was
really cool
and um
these days I'm I'm trying to have that
psychological change and through
contrary action
whatever I think like my there's a
saying is my best ideas got me where I
am today
you know and that's something that I
have to take into mind is that you know
just because it seems like a good idea
to me doesn't mean it is
you know I have to play that tape
forward I have to understand that
you know
just because Something's Gonna feel good
in the moment doesn't mean that I can
doesn't mean that a week from then I'm
gonna not gonna be in the gutter you
know
with infection dying you know it's I get
really bad really quickly what's the the
darkest your life got
well first off how many years were you
living like that
um so I um
I've struggled with addiction for a
really long time I I think I tried meth
for the first time
was like the first hard drug I did I
tried it when I was like
God early teens you know it would have
been like I would have been like just
probably 13. how old are you now I'm 24.
yeah
yeah I I just turned 24 in September so
how dark did your life get when you were
on the streets honestly living out here
right that that day that I ran into you
um probably like the dark my really my
rock rock bottom of like near death was
probably a week or so after that it was
um
like I said you know Max's uh adopted
family
they uh ended up finally getting me an
Uber to the hospital because the EMTs
wouldn't even take me
yeah they said you need help but not our
help
they're like the bus is that way take
the bus I was like they won't let me on
the bus I can't get up
I can't walk dude
and um
so they uh
Amy Max's uh adopted mother ended up
calling an Uber for some reason the Uber
driver decided to let me in take me to
um Ronald Reagan UCLA Hospital
sat in the waiting room for 12 hours
until my dad finally got my insurance
info to them right up immediately when I
got my insurance
and Max stayed with me as long as he
could you know he was very like
very supportive you know Max was nothing
but there for me so there's some
confusion about Max's yeah so max um max
is born Max I didn't have Max born
female identifies as male
um I'm lucky to still have Max in my
life is one of my best friends we're no
longer a couple per se
but we talk on a regular basis actually
talked to Max this morning
um I'm super proud of him how is Max
doing Max is better Max got on
supplicating recently which for anyone
who doesn't know supplicate is um an
extended release monthly shot that's an
opiate blocker so you can't it helps
with Cravings with like so it's like
Suboxone but extended release you know
and it helps with cravings and it keeps
you from getting high on opiates so it's
like a chastity belt for for your opiate
receptors what are you you are using
anything like that absolutely not
nothing at all I'm completely sober
having for 30 days
you just went like cold turkey no I so I
went to a um
what happened was um
I uh
the first time I got sober since the
last time I saw you I was in Milwaukee
living with Max I was strung out on
heroin and crack up there
and Max had had enough I was just being
a scumbag you know not like not like
unfaithful to Max or anything like that
but I was just being your classic
crackhead I was selling everything I was
[__] people over [__] Max over
even it was like I said nothing but
there for me and um max finally had
enough of it was like look you need to
get back into treatment this isn't good
so I called my buddy Larry from new
Origins who's a great dude
um and he was like look I'll get you in
some more dude like just get on the
plane get there
so I flew out of Milwaukee had a layover
in Detroit
um and then I uh
I ended up at LAX airport coming down
the escalator kicking really hard and I
saw a dude there I was like that's got
to be him it's like you know like if
you've been in recovery you can kind of
just spot somebody and you know and so
he was like pointed at me I'm like
that's me you know and uh he took me to
the 7-Eleven right right by the airport
bought me some cigarettes bought me
something to eat and I was still it's
really bad off this was in November of
last year
and um
they I went to where I'm at now actually
I was my first time there and uh they
did nothing but take care of me accepted
me were there for me and um I ended up
graduating from there after 30 days went
back to New Origins which is like my
home away from home that's where I'm
gonna be headed to on Monday as well
and um
I um I um
ended up going there and I I was there
for a couple months I had just about 90
days and I got I got caught tattooing my
homeboy
um a statue in his forehead it's kind of
obvious you know I would have been kind
of pushing it a little bit and they're
like look dude like we love you but we
gotta have some kind of repercussions
dude you can't just do whatever you want
and that's always been my issues even
when I'm sober I just kind of my
behavior doesn't really change it's just
my environment and my toxicology changes
so I um I was like well you know
whatever blah blah blah this on the
other started building a bunch of
resentments about it and stuff like well
we'll get you in somewhere I was like
okay
so they got me into a place in Marina
del Rey I stayed there overnight I was
talking to some other chick at this time
and um
it was a
very um
it was toxic
to say the least you know it was very
codependent very much um
you know uh and she had uh gotten kicked
out of her mother's house that same day
that I got kicked out of there
and she got picked up by some dude that
was creeping on her and [__] like that
you know I mean I throw my Captain Save
A whole cape and I uh
told her I was like you know like tell
him to come pick me up I'm your best
friend or whatever you hadn't seen me in
forever and I'll handle it
and we got him to drop us off in
Huntington Beach uh I had 20 I had 40 in
my pockets with nothing but the
intention to relapse
and um
I Got High
um
we're getting high for about a week and
we were in a hotel in Garden Grove
and she was wigging out thinking I was
gonna die as meth will do to people and
she called an ambulance not thinking
that I had warrants in LA
so I got arrested went to jail for a
little over a week
and uh this place in San Jose got me out
and um
they I ended up getting uh the boot from
there within 24 hours because the
clients were scared of me they hadn't
even met me really yet but they just saw
me like scared of me
whatever you know fine by me don't want
to be there if that's the way I feel
I went to a place in Fresno it was all
right I just didn't eat along with
people very well there and so I finally
called profound where I'm at now and I
uh
I uh you know got in there and I I was I
graduated on Monday
I'm
feeling
emotionally mentally physically
spiritually all of that a lot better
I um been going to the gym that's become
my new thing
I really enjoyed being able to work out
and you know see progress in myself
because it's just really it's a matter
of changing that self-destructive
tendency for bettering myself I mean me
and like
one of my buddies from rehab months ago
his name is Greer he's a really good
friend of mine he um hit me up he's he
hadn't even seen my interview and he was
like Hey dude I've been hitting up all
my friends who I think might be
interested have interesting stories want
to start a podcast I'm like dude you
found the right [__]
and we had uh we started when we got
like one episode out but it's um it's
kind of a little a little low budget
phone phone microphones and everything
you know but um
we're working through it man I'm just
trying to you know spread that hope that
you know like for people that have seen
how how bad I am which is a lot of
people you know that's crazy like when
you interviewed me I had no clue like I
had heard of your channel and stuff like
that I just had no clue like my sister
found out I was using because of that my
mom found out I was using because of
that those are right yeah they were
gonna find out either way it's and I
wasn't going to tell them of course you
know so
I think that it was really a wake-up
call for a lot of people as to how bad
off I was
and um
it's easy to tell you know that um you
know that was after four months of using
I got from looking like this back to
that
I drop weight so quick because I don't
eat I've got better things to do
you know
you know food costs money out here
money's for drugs and I'll eat all the
trash can if I want to
tell me what it took for you mentally to
to do all this it took losing Max was
what it was it took it took Max cutting
cutting off our relationship was what it
was I I didn't
I had that slip up but
I didn't it I I wasn't using a good
conscience I felt guilty the whole time
about it
it really took losing someone
it took losing a relationship that I
that I cherished and someone that I
loved still to this day dearly like you
know me and Max are on good terms you
know Max is proud of me I'm proud of him
you know but it's
it took that relationship ending because
of my
Shenanigans to uh
to really open my eyes to the fact that
dude I'm [__] up it's not it you know
because I think that
Max stuck by me as long as he could
and it was um something I I I took for
granted
you know the face tattoos that you have
were these done while you were High
um a lot of them yeah a lot of them were
um I got the Black Flag one but my
eyebrow while I was sober my buddy
Anthony he's up and coming kind of guy
he's just doing his thing but uh he he
did that at uh Redland skate park I was
laid out on the picnic table I was like
dude run it
the whole time everyone was like yo this
that and the other you know I was like
yeah the upside down cross on your
forehead is going to keep you from
working at Starbucks
it's kept me from working at more than
Starbucks man
I um
I don't regret my face tattoos I think
that they're um definitely I call them I
call them a [__] armor
because people that are going to judge
me based on my tattoos
when they get to know me
you know if someone does not gonna take
the time to get to know somebody
regardless of if it's me or anyone else
who looks different I don't want to
associate with that person
because you know that's the kind of
person you you [__] up a little
something or other than their out the
door you know I don't like I don't like
people that have that superficial
you know oh if you don't look like a
functioning member of society I'll never
trust you you know
I'm good
yeah
it's uh
it's been a long road man feels like
it's been longer than seven months
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
or is this all just a learning process
it's a learning process but I um
I think me and me and Max have actually
discussed there's a lot of things we
both would have done differently I think
that the only that's one of my only
regrets in life is that relationship
being over
it's uh something I still struggle with
and it is going is is working out
becoming like your new obsession it is
yeah absolutely it's something that I uh
I've seen a lot of people that are
alcoholics or whatever and they need to
go to the gym or run or do yeah no it's
that endorphin release is what it is
it's the it's the it's the
seeing progress
and
it's a lot of also seeing people say oh
my God you look so much better
and
believing that knowing that I look a lot
better
you know because I think anyone can gain
weight in recovery
but getting it in the right places is
where it's at you know like that's
it's something that I uh I crave you
know is to have
um a healthy image you know to look
to look like I'm doing well how much of
all this whether you're doing well or or
falling apart
is all is about
what you subconsciously believe about
yourself
like what you believe you deserve in
life I think that um
something that I heard is uh I can't
remember who said it I wish I could but
it's if we all got what we deserved none
of us would be around
I think that I'm glad I don't get what I
deserve because I'd be I'd be broken
deadline in a ditch somewhere but I
think that
like I said last time everyone deserves
a chance and I try to give people
chances
so I'm I'm super grateful when people
give me chances
if it wasn't for second third and 103rd
chances I wouldn't be here today
you know
but um would you like to be doing in
five five years
um
hopefully uh either
I mean I'd like to work in treatment
that'd be that'd be awesome I'd love to
do like Addiction Counseling and also
maybe something like podcasting on the
side
and I think that that's something that's
a great Avenue with the explosion of
media and all that stuff these days is
the ability to put your story out there
for millions of people to see
and like that's something that I I
that's one of the biggest things that
I've taken out of our first interview
was that that platform that like you
know some people just see it as oh you
know
I got paid to do an interview blah blah
and they don't even give a [__] about
the impact that they make on people
you know dude I like that's why I mean I
can give a [__] less about money right
now dude I don't care I want people to
see that you can go from where I was to
where I am now and even farther yeah
you're a poster child for Recovery
that's right
I uh it's one of the main reasons that
uh I wanted to do this is because I I
want
people to see that it can be done
it can be done with someone who is as
bad off as I was or worse
you know and you can get to the point
where you know you you I've got new
shoes new pants new shirt on you know
I'm I'm
I've got you know I'm doing well you
know I'm I've I've got money in my
account I've got [__] food stamps you
know I've got stuff that I I have my own
resources
I I love that
I love being self-sufficient because
it's not something I've had much of in
my life
so it's nice
you know
he said what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned from all
this this journey of years
that um
I hate to say that corny don't use no
matter what but that's one of them and
I'd say um
one of the truly most important things
is anything that I put before my
recovery I'm going to lose because if I
don't put my recovery first
then um
everything else that I've gained in that
process is going to fall away because
I'm going to lose sight of my recovery
you know I I have to work a program I
have to do my [__] I can't just smoke a
joint I can't just have a beer because
at the end of that joint I'm not have a
needle in my arm at any of that beer I'm
gonna have handcuffs on my wrist you
know because I don't just have one
I don't just smoke weed occasionally I
can't dude anything I do I'm
doing more of it you know I have the
addiction I have the disease more you
know that's I have I have that
innate desire to burn everything down
and I have to do contrary action every
day
I go to I go to I go to meetings every
at least five meetings a week usually
that's what I do you know I go and I I
listen to the experience strength and
Hope from other people that have been
where I've been
you know and it's it's amazing to see
just it's just that feeling of
identifying with another addicts or
alcoholic and seeing someone and being
like yo I like what you have I want that
you know and that's that's where that
hope comes from and that's what I hope
to do today as well I think this talk
might give
people who have family members that are
totally gone and lost might give them
hope yeah and I will I will say I mean
can you what would you say to somebody
who's got a a sibling or a child who is
just don't give up but don't enable
don't I mean that's one thing I'll give
my mom is she she didn't give up on me
but she damn sure didn't enable me
not for years you know she was in the
early stages when I could kind of keep
it under wraps
maybe a little bit but dude you know
and also tell your loved ones you love
them you know you never know if it's the
last time you're gonna talk to them
if you talk to one of your loved ones
that you know is struggling or even if
you don't know they're struggling tell
them you love them you never know
whether it's their first time trying
something they OD and die off of it or
it's their millionth time you never know
the overdose rates are ridiculous I
think it's like one every 11 minutes
someone overdoses and dies off fentanyl
yeah that smells crazy it's insane man
all right Sid thank you so much for uh
coming back thank you sir so proud of
you thank you madam stay on track man
absolutely man amazing thank you thanks
man